the decision to launch the novel
operation has just been taken it is
probably the first time European Union
takes the issue of migration so
seriously in such a fast way
today we discuss the dramatic situation
in the Mediterranean at the highest
political level saving the life of
innocent people is the number one
priority for us but saving life is not
just about rescuing people at sea it is
also about stopping the smugglers and
addressing illegal migration
we are going today at three o'clock to
discuss this military operation because
it obviously has lots of political
implications
we're going to discuss today the
operation plan of the new mission unifor
Mediterranean the operation plan is of
course always a very detailed plan it's
I think something like 700 pages I know
that document has been distributed not
so long ago but then again we work here
now on a very tight schedule dime frames
because of course the the need to act
this is quite high
I hope everybody is in because this is a
meeting in restricted format since we
discuss a confidential document have to
ask you also not to use your cell phones
or tablets or computers
Horace oh sure do commit abilities
really o.o present only chef de tanishaa
dezhou may lose an au travail yes yolo
planned operation present a palo
commonality asean news al-ahmadi see
available Entre Nous pop over 4 million
avg diametre ensuite landy Quinn
decisions gratis para Lehman is shauna
fascinante yo con le pone de la Creuset
not see below so sunny traffic on move
along Canelo processes approval apply a
G a G Scott party my Amiga sua para
mañana kiss only model in your 10
this is the second for generation
conference and I hope that at the end of
this is beating I will be in a position
to recommend the launch of beautiful
meadow bridge
okay prefers to legal act which would
allow you've been Union to launch the
operation in Mediterranean we normally
after a political decision is taken in
pc then this is our group relics which
translates the political will of the
member states in the legal act which
would then allow member states to
contribute forces for this operation
today is Monday 22nd June we are in
Luxembourg and behind me in this room
the members of the committee of
permanent representatives will soon be
meeting to look at the draft operation
plan the committee of permanent
representatives is the highest
preparatory body in the Council of the
European Union they prepare what the
ministers will then decide when they
meet in a couple of hours as Foreign
Affairs Council
less than two months ago the European
Council tasked us to prepare an
operation in the Mediterranean to save
lives first of all and disrupt the
business model of human traffickers and
smugglers the operation is being
launched today the targets let me be
very clear the targets are not the
migrants the targets are those that are
making money on their lives and to open
on their debts